Chazz the autonomous Principality of
Chazz which is that six block anarchist
zone in Seattle stands for the Capitol
Hill autonomous zone has changed its
name to chop which is a little more
honest to me when they start bringing in
the guillotines chop stands for Capitol
Hill organized protests why did they
change the name I kid you not
they changed the name so that they could
keep getting welfare checks people
people familiar with the situation have
said this was a big reason why they
changed the name because if you're an
autonomous state an autonomous country
then you're not allowed to get welfare
checks from other countries I guess you
could get foreign aid which is sort of a
welfare check from our country we give
it to way too many people but probably
Chazz wasn't going to get too much
foreign aid so they changed it to chop
so they can keep getting their welfare
checks and their food stamps and all the
government goodies from the United
States all the while protesting the
United States they also were a little
worried that by declaring themselves an
autonomous country it would give the
federal government more of an
opportunity to crack down on them
whereas if they're just saying it's a
protest then the government won't crack
down government should crack down this
has gone on too long okay and
conservatives always play it slow they
play it soft I'll give you an example in
the courts the Left says we're gonna
we're going to put up leftist judges who
are going to give us leftist outcomes
and we're gonna ask them case by case
how they would rule and we're gonna get
good leftists leftists never put up a
judge and then accidentally get a
conservative conservatives often put up
judges and accidentally get leftists and
liberals because we do it all we go so
backwards we say okay we're gonna put up
judges who they're not conservative but
they're going to give us an outcome that
is you know it's based on this other
judicial philosophy and we might not
always like the outcomes but it'll it'll
be good and we actually can't ask them
about any cases and how they would rule
but hopefully they'll be okay and as so
anyway let's hope everything
works out for the best and then you get
David Souter a turncoat Republican
appointed judge who became a liberal you
get Sandra Day O'Connor did you get John
dinner and dinner to toe you get John
Roberts ditto you get Kennedy ditto
you get Neil Gorsuch did oka happens
time and time again we we don't use
force we get this radical movement like
BLM which is openly founded by Marxists
BLM which is based on a lie the lie of
Ferguson that that Michael Brown was
executed in Ferguson with his hands up
saying don't shoot completely
contradicted by grand jury by
eyewitnesses by black eye witnesses by
the multiple autopsies by everything
it's still based on this lie and some
conservatives say well we should try to
come to an understanding with it no
there's no understanding you're buying
into the lie that BLM is about black
lives mattering it's not you're buying
into the lie that these are peaceful
protesters they're not they're rioters
who created their own autonomous country
you're buying into the lie that it's an
organized protest go in there with force
and stop them from occupying streets
there we're now getting word that
they're they're running an extortion
racket on businesses in the area that's
not fair we know that they're they're
using unjust force on other people we
know that they're that these riders have
been attacking people burning down
buildings murdering people stop it stop
allowing this to happen to use force no
middle ground stand in the middle of the
road you're gonna get hit by a truck a
lot more radicalism coming down the pike
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]